KEVIN: Yeah.
-Yo, dude, you
gotta come out, man.
KEVIN: Why?
-Hey man, we gotta talk
to you about something.
KEVIN: About what?
-Yo man, just come
out the goddamn door.
-I really don't
understand y'all.
Like y'all know how I am.
I like my space, man.
That's my alone time right now.
-Dude, Joey's been
acting weird, man.
-Ever since "Real
Husbands," or "Hollywood,"
whatever that thing called,
y'all won an Image Award.
-Weird how?
What are you talking about?
-You know how we used to make
fun of his vests all the time?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, well he made
a complete 180.
And I don't mean in a good way.
-OK.
You know what?
You guys sound like haters.
-Hm.
-I'm being honest with you.
Right now, you both
sound like haters.
And I, I thought that
we were all friends.
I thought that we were
all on the same page
as far as keeping
each other afloat,
being uplifting gentlemen.
If that man wants to enjoy
the fruits of his labor,
you let him.
He's good.
Leave Joey alone.
OK?
-He good.
He good.
-I know he's good.
-OK.
Wait till you see this.
-See what?
-Uh, Joey?
-Hey, whoa, Spank-a-dank,
slide it, slide it, slide it,
turned it out!
Turn out!
-Turn, turn up.
-Turn up too.
That's it.
-Yo Kev, got 'em up.
Two for you.
Two for my [bleep].
-Shake your hands?
What is that?
-Ooh, ooh.
-OK.
-Brought my thoughts.
-Your what?
OK.
-Ladies, turn it out.
-What the?
KEVIN: OK.
-Here we go.
KEVIN: Joey-- did Joey just make
white girls twerk on command?
-Yeah, yeah.
They just twerked on command.
-Joey, you got a gold tooth now?
-Just take one these out
and get it on your tooth.
-You're spending your
money on the wrong thing.
-Fruits of labor.
Fruits of labor.
-No, this, this, this is--
I forgot how much this cost,
but it's a lot.
-Stop.
-Sorry?
-Joey, when, when, I'm
talking to you, can you--
-Turn out.
-Can you get the [bleep]
hair out your eye?
Can you look at
me, please, Joey?
Dude, what are you doing?
-No, I'm ready for the special.
-No, no, Joey.
Look at me.
You're not about
to embarrass me.
Get this off your damn head.
-Hey!
Hey, hey!
-Get your ass in here.
-Hey, you can't go take my--
-Let me talk to you.
-Hey, y'all take the
wig, and the white women,
and you get them outta here.
-Oh no!
Not my white women!
-Joey, you going to
lose the white women!
-Not my white women!
-All right.
That's my Joey right there.
You look good.
-No white women.
Go get 'em, Joey.
-All right.
-Leave me the [bleep]
alone, please.